à son arrivée en france dans les
toilettes de l'aéroport paris-charles de
gaulle le premier geste symbolique de
pavel filatiers f
voilà ce sont mes papiers
la carte d'identité militaire
mon passeport de citoyen russe
le jem la russie j'aime les russes
mais toutim n'est pas la rue si le
gouvernement n'est pas la russie poutine
va te faire voir
après 48 heures au centre de rétention
nous rencontrons l'ancien militaire de
34 ans désormais considéré comme
déserteur par la russie il est autorisé
à entrer en france il va faire avec son
avocate une demande de droit d'asile son
témoignage est accablant sur la guerre
en ukraine mené par vladimir poutine
on s'entretue et entre militaires russes
et ukrainiens mais je voyais que nous
étions aussi en train de tuer des civils
il ya eu beaucoup de civils
bon bien sûr j'ai pu être cruel parfois
mais je ne pouvais pas accepter ce qui
se passait
nous arrivions et nous détruisions des
villes entières ont rasé tout
pavel fils à kiev était un soldat
d'élite un commando parachutiste il
affirme n'avoir commis aucune exaction
ils étaient prêts à mourir pour son pays
mais après deux mois de guerre en
première ligne il dénonce une guerre
inutile
aujourd'hui beaucoup de militaires
russes refusent tout simplement d'aller
à la guerre et ceux qui y vont non pas
de motivation ni droite ou d'ailleurs
c'est pour cela que poutine essaye de
recruter des gens en prison et des
filles
blessé en mai le soldat d'élite est
écarté de la ligne de pau fini les
tranchées et les combats c'est à
l'hôpital qu'il va commencer à écrire
sur la guerre son récit est intitulé off
un appel à l'aide équivalent un sos il y
raconte la désorganisation de l'armée
russe et les morts inutiles un site
internet russe publie des extraits puis
la chaîne d'un militant des droits de
l'homme goulag ou point net invite pavel
fils et retief
vous êtes le seul à briser le silence
dans l'armée russe est ce qu'aujourd'hui
vous êtes devenu l'homme à abattre par
vladimir poutine
je voulais juste réveillé les
consciences pour que les gens se rendent
compte de ce qui est vrai si vous
allumez la télévision vous allez
entendre les russes dire qu'ils chassent
les nazis d'ukraine et que cette
opération c'est pour libérer la
population de ces nazis
j'ai appris que mon commandement avait
demandé 15 ans de prison pour moi en
m'accusant de diffamation contre l'armée
et se retrouver en prison en russie
c'est être à la merci de l'état on peut
être torturés humiliés c'est une bonne
raison pour quitter le pays
c'était devenu pour eux un traître je
prédis un ennemi
il a peur pour sa vie et doit quitter le
pays dès que possible
après un mois de cavale il est exfiltré
par des lanceurs d'alert et arrive à
paris il y a quelques jours
aujourd'hui je pense que beaucoup de
russes ne veulent pas de cette guerre
malgré ce que raconte
l'ukraine c'est une honte pour notre
pays